this may look like a typical casino
floor but there's no gamblers no chips
changing hands or free drinks
that's because this is live dealing a
type of online gambling new to the us in
which games are broadcast to players
phones
boom
that's what i'm talking about no matter
where you look today you've likely
encountered these ads for online
gambling i put a million books in up to
five draftkings sports book accounts
none of these commercials would have
been possible without a 2018 supreme
court decision that struck down the
federal sports gambling ban and
triggered an accelerated adoption of
online gambling across the u.s
today six states mostly in the northeast
allow for online casino games like
blackjack roulette and baccarat
one of the new entrants into the market
is playtech
so the security in this building seems
pretty high why is that yeah
security is the first priority here i
sat down with playtex managing director
for live casino ido heighten so we're
sitting here in an office building in
southfield michigan but all around us it
looks like a casino so
where are we right now so we are
in michigan we cannot say the actual
address this is one of our studios looks
like a casino but it's not there is no
uh gambling activities happening here
within the facility here basically we
operate the games we train the dealers
and and make the whole full-blown
product
playtech is a gambling technology
company that offers live dealing
where dealers flip cards and spin
roulette wheels in front of cameras for
gamblers at home on their phones so if
i'm in michigan i can open an app and
bet on one of the games happening here
correct correct not far away from us
there are live games being operated now
why develop a whole live studio why not
just have animated games on an app that
someone can gamble on around 13 14 years
ago already we started establishing sort
of a sidekick to our regular casino
games which were a live casino game
stream people could sit at the table and
also bet with a live dealer you're one
step closer to that 1000 golden pool
okay here we go
then the players started piling up more
and more into those tables because the
experience that you give is as close as
you can get to a land-based casino
experience
also takes away that sort of loneliness
element when you sit at your home and
bet alone
although playtech is a big player in
online gambling gamblers themselves
might not necessarily be familiar with
the name
that's because a big part of playtex
business is providing various online
gaming products to a variety of licensed
companies around the world
welcome to our sports bar studio our
sports ball strategy is basically
bringing
some of the sports book players some of
the sports fans and allowing them to
interact with sports events while they
also play our game so here you can see
cashback blackjack that's a scalable
version of a blackjack table that allows
unlimited amount of players to sit at
the same table playing blackjack this is
part of our training module to
eventually get our presenters our
dealers when they go live with a certain
experience to really know
what is the script without having a
script and gamblers online they actually
can create a relationship yeah that's
the community aspect that is
making live unique
online casino betting is a small but
growing industry in the us that many
gambling companies hope will become
increasingly legalized in much the same
way mobile sports betting already has
been in many states
in the u.s the biggest online casino
market is in new jersey this graph
charts the steady increase in revenue
seen by the garden state since 2017
i see a big red button what's going on
here this is um buffalo blitz live
buffalo blitz is a slow concept that
allows multiple players to sit and play
on the same slot and allows you to
interact with the dealer allows you to
interact with other players on the chat
although the expansion of legal gambling
generates significant tax revenue for
states problem gambling advocates are
concerned about a potential rise in
addiction so when you talk about 24 7
availability at home
you know how do you address gambling
addiction already the websites that we
work with they are also
in complying with
regulations that you know apply to them
and a player cannot bet more than he can
and cannot deposit more than he's
allowed we have functions that's called
hosts gaming hosts people that are
actually on the floor not dealing the
tables and if we see if somebody's
betting over his abilities we have a way
that our system can flag those players
this is far away from being a
hit-and-run operation
casinos in las vegas and around the
world shut down when the pandemic began
leaving gambler searching for options at
home
in recent months tourists have flocked
back but casino operators acknowledge
that online betting is here to stay so
does that mean casinos in real life are
going away absolutely not first of all
you know we are
their extension to the online so a lot
of our licensees clients basically are
land-based casinos that wants to extend
their business and move to the online
and no matter how great the experience
that we're going to give here it's still
an online experience i think that the
land-based
experience
gives a completely different value
the arrival of live dealing in the u.s
comes amid transformation for the
gambling industry in recent years more
and more states are embracing new forms
of betting as a lucrative source of tax
revenue but with the recent surge in
gambling ads and the 24 7 availability
of wagering at home
questions remain about the long-term
impact on americans